to learn how far the Democrats have
shifted from the mainstream on
immigration let's compare the old
Kirsten Gillibrand to the latest
iteration now before she was appointed
to replace Hillary Clinton a senator
from New York in 2009
congresswoman Gillibrand opposed amnesty
for legal immigrants she opposed a
proposal to let illegal immigrants
obtain driver's licenses in New York she
supported making English the official
language of the United States
well now let's fast-forward to last
night I don't think ice today is working
as intended you think you should get rid
of the agency I believe that it has
become a deportation force and I think
you should separate the criminal justice
from the immigration issues and I think
you should reimagine ice under a new
agency with a very different mission and
take those two missions out and that's
why I believe you should get rid of it
start over
reimagine it and build something that
actually works well two things are clear
from Gillibrand about-face on
immigration she's clearly running for
president in 2020 no doubt about it and
more Democrats now see the radical
proposal to abolish ice well that's a
winning issue and it's fountains but
better than saying I'm for open waters
well are they right let's debate that
with American Conservative Union
President match lap in former dancey
deputy press secretary Jose Arista munot
Jose let's start with you I'm wondering
if this is the right gamble for the
Democrats
I watched Chuck Schumer after Maxine
Waters last week and come out on Monday
and I remember when Chuck Schumer that's
how long I've been around I remember
when he ran for Congress okay in like
1986 or whatever that was he's a pretty
wilykat it's pretty smart and he thought
that waters was getting a little too
heated in a rhetoric and so forth and I
imagine he's worried about this as well
because Democrats still have to attract
blue-collar workers that is regular
run-of-the-mill people who aren't all
that political when they hear abolish
ice they hear abolish safety are you
worried about that it's a good point you
bring forth and that's a Democrat I can
tell you this I don't necessarily think
that we need to
polish ice once and for all but I do
think in the last couple of years
especially under a trump administration
I mean I agree with the senator it has
become a deportation force so we need to
make sure at least if we're not gonna
abolish it completely let's have a
conversation or where the resources
should be implemented when it comes to
ice so let's let's talk Matt about what
is happening with Congress members of
Congress because there is a congressman
privilege I Paul who was at this big
protest yesterday on Capitol Hill they
took over the heart Senate office
building they arrested 500 people that's
what the Capitol Police was up to
yesterday
and I want you to listen closely to what
she said I have been working on
immigration issues for 20 years and the
enforcement functions which need to be
here in a country as ours we do have
immigration laws they do need to be
enforced but those functions don't need
to be in an agency that has become a
rogue agency that literally has no
accountability to Congress around the
hundreds of millions of dollars that we
spent has no accountability Matt is that
kind of is that it turn a conservative
twist on what sounds like kind of a
radical idea I mean you want agencies to
be accountable to somebody so that's the
new thing they're rogue they've gone
rogue deportation force kids and cages
etc yeah you know ice did all the same
things under President Obama Laura but
you never read any of these stories you
never read about this rogue agency that
was somehow out of bounds and by the way
they get all their money from Congress
and you know they're the executive
branch and Congress has oversight over
them and they should do that
aggressively but the fact is is this
you're gonna have we created ice under
the Bush years because at the end of the
day you have to have some part of the
federal government that enforces our
border where they're going to enforce it
or not and when you enforce the border
it comes down to individual personal
stories and the left will try to make it
sound like we're being cool and and
somehow inhumane but the fact is when
you let criminals come over the border
and we have invented them it hurts
immigrant communities when people get to
cut in line they're cutting in line over
other people from
entries who were waiting in line to come
here legally so it's actually these
immigrant communities that are hurt when
we don't enforce our well they also Jose
help with human trafficking stopping
drugs from coming into the country they
have a lot on their plate and again I
feel it and see it that the energy and
the Democratic Party is on the far left
that's what it's like the Bernie crowd
like take over the heart Senate office
building March up you know get your
plastic cuffs on make the photo tweet it
selfie I just I gotta say I'm just as a
matter of political analysis yeah I
don't get it how is that a political
strategy for expanding your base well a
few things and I and not brought a good
point forth and he's saying that we're
talking about ice been an agency that's
gone wrong and all these sort of things
look they're ice officials former
officials who have come forward and said
we need to do something about this
agency because you said it we are ice as
an agency they're supposed to be going
against transnational crime organization
they also deport people like Obama
deported people who you were you talking
about that back then I was I was talking
about that but but look why don't we and
I've said this time and time again on
your show if we care about so much about
the future of this country and we care
about about all the immigrants here that
right now what they have is amnesty the
11 million who are in this country now
they haven't so we're gonna have another
million if we don't we don't have a nice
force that's able to deport people who
cross our border illegally get
deportation orders and have to go home
let's look let's do people like any of
them Kingdom or now shouldn't be
deported a hundred percent of you an
ms-13 gang member is only if you're
there well know if you're a real
criminal if you're a real critic you've
cooked you've committed serious crimes
rapes across the border in your mind
crossing the border itself you cross the
border maybe bring someone else's kid
with you maybe you come with a group of
people leave should you should you be
sent home you should at least go before
a judge and see if you have a case for
asylum which by the way right now
President Trump and Jeff session I try
not change its it the courts have
already determined due process does not
require a judge if you cross the border
illegally it doesn't require an
immediate basic human rights is basic
right that's it that's it Matt
here's one other thing and then we're
gonna go this poll that came out
yesterday 84% according to the mark Penn
poll that he just did said that you
arrest illegal immigrants for crimes
they should be required to notify the
authorities immigration authorities take
them into custody and that's an anti
sanctuary cities mindset that's clearly
in the voting public now I think people
feel very uncomfortable about like
large-scale deportations I don't think a
lot of people want to see that but they
do want to see crime Jose said they do
want to see crimes right tackled and
dealt with and the idea of just letting
people who cross the border illegally
can stay I don't I don't see the big
groundswell for that except among the
fringe yeah so for Republicans and
conservatives immigration is about the
law for Democrats it about it's about
emotion and when you if you want to look
at the politics of immigration there are
two things that are absolutely right
mark Pence a study shows that which is
this concept of us not being aware of
the criminals that live amongst us in
this concept of sanctuary cities which
are now sanctuary counties and states
that is bad politics all over the other
thing is is that most Americans almost
50% of them would compare to all the
other options they believe that people
adults who crossed the border illegally
simply should be sent home immediately
the politics of the extreme left on this
for the Democratic Party and immigration
might sound it to their base it's gonna
help Republicans come November alright
gentlemen we'll see I could go either
way perhaps but we'll see thank you so
much